mr. way Clark Kent Daily Planet what's  your position on the bath vigilante in  Gotham I've been a fan of DC and the  Justice League for a long time everybody  is this mean something all some people  have the amazing thing that we've gotten  from Batman V Superman is really a  doorway that opens that world to us we  got Suicide Squad coming in august which  is really exciting it's gonna be super  fun we have the one woman movie that  we're working on and then of course we  have justice league that I start  shooting in a couple weeks  we're gonna have a movie with Superman  Batman flash Aquaman Wonder Woman cyborg  it's almost like an impossible thing to  hope for it and you look at it on paper  like wow it's incredible is that really  possible I'm really excited to dig my  teeth into that I'm really hoping to  bring a really big IMAX experience back  from just asleep and really give back to  the fans the movie that people have been  waiting